wir fassen noch einmal zusammen der
berliner senat hat sowohl die russische
als auch die ukrainische flagge an
verschiedenen gedenkorten verboten grund
das würdevolle gedenken an das ende des
zweiten weltkrieges gestern und heute
solle so geschützt werden die polizei
hat dann die ukrainische flagge eben bei
den gedenkfeierlichkeiten in berlin
eingeräumt darüber müssen wir sprechen
mit bild chefredakteur johannes buhl
jetzt bei uns im studio ein morgen wie
johannes also macht deutschland sich
nicht mit diesen bildern jetzt zum
gespött der welt welches signal senden
wir damit doch komplett wir machen uns
zum gespött der welt es ist peinlich ist
es aber mehr als eine peinlichkeit das
zeigt dass wir die
politische lage nicht wirklich richtig
einschätzen in diesem land wenn man nun
sagt das ist das gedenken zum ende des
zweiten weltkriegs dann muss man doch
sagen was haben wir aus dem zweiten
weltkrieg eigentlich gelernt und wir
hätten doch daraus vor allem lernen
müssen dass es manchmal eben eine sehr
klare rollenverteilung gibt die guten
und die bösen und in diesem konflikt ist
es nun ganz glasklar dass die russen die
bösen sind sie haben das land
angegriffen sie habe die ukraine
attackiert sie hatten keinen grund dazu
sie morden sie vergewaltigen sie foltern
in der ukraine und dass wir nun sagen
wir behandeln diese flaggen gleich von
den angegriffenen von den opfern und die
flagge der täter das ist ein fataler
fehler und dem rest der welt wird über
uns gelacht allerdings wird über uns
auch bereits die stirn gerunzelt weil
sich natürlich mehr und mehr nationen
fragen zuallererst die ukrainische wie
feststeht deutschland eigentlich an der
seite der freiheit danach jannis wird ja
werden diese beiden fragen ja eigentlich
durch diese aktion der gleichgesetzt
lass uns da noch mal wirklich auch den
finger in die wunde legen legen welches
signal man damit setzt indem man beide
flaggen pauschal verbietet
ja man zeigt damit eben dass man die
situation beider länder praktisch gleich
betrachtet oder eine andere
interpretationsmöglichkeit ist dass man
einfach gar keine aufregung möchte und
sagt weder die eine noch die andere
seite dürfen eine flagge zeigen dann
kann auch kann es auch gar keins laut
geben das wiederum würde von einer
enormen kurzsichtigkeit zeugen und auch
von einer geschichtsvergessenheit von
einer blindheit auch der aktuellen
situation gegenüber wie kann man das
gleichsetzen das eigene land wird
angegriffen das andere land ist der
angreifer das ist einfach komplett
falsch eine eine fehlentscheidung ganz
egal was die grundlage ist hier hat das
wirklich jedem beteiligten an
fingerspitzengefühl nicht nur an
fingerspitzengefühl auch an
grundsätzlichen politischen verständnis
für die situation der gegenwart gefehlt
das ist eine blamage ist es ehrlich
gesagt eine katastrophe und wir müssen
uns nicht wundern wenn die ukraine keine
lust hat deutsche politikerinnen und
politiker zu empfangen wenn man eben
bilder sieht wie dieses das eine
ukrainische fahne in deutschland während
in der ukraine mutige menschen auch
unsere freiheit verteidigen eingerollt
wird dann kann ich sehr gut verstehen
wenn der ukrainische präsident sagt oder
der bürgermeister von kiew wir brauchen
nun nicht unbedingt deutsche politiker
in der ukraine vielleicht kommt der eine
oder andere ja noch darauf dass er sagt
gut vielleicht sollte man hier jetzt ein
bisschen schadensbegrenzung betreiben um
eben ihr habt das wieder gutzumachen was
man da falsch gemacht hat wie könnte das
gelingen johannes ja das ist eine sehr
schwierige frage denn deutschland
versucht ja seit vielen tagen und wochen
schadensbegrenzung zu betreiben denn
zunächst mal muss deutschland
schadensbegrenzung dafür betreiben in
den letzten jahren jahrzehnten fast eine
extrem putin freundliche politik
gefahren zu haben dabei sich von ganz
klaren sachverhalten nicht beeindruckt
beeindruckt zu haben und insgesamt putin
den weg nach europa geebnet zu haben
denn das ist also schon mal die
grundvoraussetzung für die deutsch
ukrainischen beziehungen nun war man
gerade so weit dass man mit viel
diplomatischer hilfe möglicherweise auch
geebnet durch die reise von friedrich
merz in die ukraine die ukraine so weit
hatte dass sie bereit waren deutsche
regierungsmitglieder zu empfangen jetzt
der nächste tiefschlag der nächsten
niederschlag für die ukraine hier werden
die flaggen des landes eingeräumt
während dort gekämpft wird auch unsere
freiheit auch unsere demokratie wird
dort verteidigt ich sagte dass bereits
denn wladimir putin hat ja ganz klar
angekündigt er will die ukraine erobern
und danach macht er nicht schluss
sondern danach kommen die nächst länder
und
er sieht die nato als feind er sieht uns
als feind
dhs wäre glasklar dass wir ganz eng an
der seite der ukraine stehen müssten wie
man das jetzt erneut kippen kann ehrlich
gesagt kann man nur auf großzügigkeit
der regierung in kiew hoffen und darauf
hoffen dass man das erklären kann mit
der irgendwie verrückten entscheidung
eines einzelnen bundeslandes der stadt
berlin in deutschland nur ich befürchte
das wird nicht klappen denn es ist eben
nicht ein einzelnes bundesland ist es
leider eine geisteshaltung die sich quer
durch die deutsche politik zieht von den
sogenannten intellektuellen gar nicht zu
sprechen und obendrein ist berlin auch
nicht irgendein bundesland sondern eben
die bundeshauptstadt insofern bleibt
wirklich nur die hoffnung dass die
ukraine sich uns gegenüber großzügig
verhalten und anerkennen dass wir
wenigstens in anderer hinsicht
angefangen haben wenn auch für meinen
geschmack viel zu zögerlich ein stück
weit zu helfen und während du sprichst
johannes sehen wir noch einmal diese
bilder wie die ukrainische fahne
eingerollt wird und es sind natürlich
bilder die um die welt gehen das sind
bilder die auch in der ukraine gesehen
werden und paul ronzheimer ist es
gelungen darüber zu sprechen mit den
klitschko-brüdern was in ihren herzen
dass in ihren köpfen vorgeht wenn sie
das in deutschland beobachten
wir wollen noch einmal kurz über die
debatte in deutschland sprechen wladimir
und vitali wir haben am wochenende
erlebt das ist bei
gedenkveranstaltung nicht erlaubt war
die ukrainische schlage dabei zu haben
an gedenkorten das hatte das land berlin
verfügt die polizei verfügt und wir
haben gesehen wie dann eine große
ukrainische flagge tatsächlich von der
polizei dort eingerollt wurde was macht
das mit euch ihr habt deutsches herz
sozusagen neben dem ukrainischen wenn
ihr diese bilder da in berlin sind kein
verständnis dafür weil vor vier wochen
durften dann russische
autos in großen mengen mit flaggen durch
die städte ziehen und durchziehen und es
war okay und die ukrainische fahne
während diesen kriegs werden
an die zerstörung von infrastruktur und
töten von zivilisten mann
die greenshoe fahrende zusammen
gefordert hat dass es gibt kein
verständnis
vitali ist auch politisch nicht doch
politisch und auf keinen fall auf
besonnene bitterli was macht das mit dir
der außenminister der ukrainische
außenminister hat das stark kritisiert
also russische und ukrainische flaggen
sind und waren am 8 9 mal verboten
ukrainische flaggen wurden richtig von
der polizei dann eingerollt was macht
das mit dir als jemand der in
deutschland wie gewohnt er ich spreche
jetzt viele bürgermeister von ganze wind
mit repräsentativen von ganz vielen der
untreue ist gebietes land jedes staates
hat so viel orange von und dass er seine
zeichen unity die zeichnen unterstützung
durch rein und deswegen schwierig zu
verstehen wieso ist so krank vorne ist
verboten wollen an diesem bestimmten
tagen ein gedanke an den gedenkort ich
verstehe aber wahrscheinlich muss keine
spannung sein und
wahrscheinlich die ausreden diese machen
war aus rhede und die brille begründen
wieso ist das aber denke ich manchmal
heute ukrainische fahne
auf das ist eine symbol für eine 7 war
von einem kampf für frieden und für
frieden und gegen den krieg und deswegen
für ein schwieriges
johannes diese reaktion ist wohl mehr
als verständlich oder mehr als
verständlich die clips kurs sagen jetzt
ganz klar ist es einfach unverständlich
aus ihrer perspektive und ich persönlich
würde mir wünschen dass wir in
deutschland vielmehr deren perspektive
wenn schon nicht einnehmen dann doch
zumindest verstehen das sind die leute
die gerade mitten in europa undenkbar
vor drei vier monaten die freiheit
verteidigen die demokratie verteidigen
und wir sollten wirklich bei unseren
entscheidungen sei es auf länderebene
wie jetzt in berlin sei es auf
bundesebene wie bei den
waffenlieferungen dass viel mehr im
mittelpunkt stellen ich habe auch immer
wieder kontakt mit vertretern anderer
nationen mit amerikanern mit briten wir
machen uns dort wirklich lächerlich die
leute verstehen es nicht die historische
situation in der ukraine ist so glasklar
und das bedeutet übrigens nicht dass man
kritik an der ukrainischen regierung
nicht formulieren usw aber das sind doch
alles themen jetzt wirklich hinten
runterfallen es ist so glasklar das eine
land greift das andere an mitten in
europa und hier nicht vollumfänglich in
jeder geste in jedem zeichen auf der
seite der angegriffene zu stehen ist ein
fataler fehler der auf uns irgendwann in
einer unbestimmten zukunft noch teuer zu
stehen kommen könnte nämlich dann wenn
wir die hilfe von alliierten benötigen
chefredakteur von bild vielen herzlichen
dank für deine analyse hier bei uns im
studio